bonjour à tous et merci l'équipe tedx de
m'avoir invité
je suis hyper content d'être là je vais
essayer de vous parler un petit peu de
moi mes projets d'entreprenariat un
petit peu d'humanitaire et surtout
beaucoup d'humanisme j'ai toujours été
bercé par le hip hop la culture hip hop
mais j'ai jamais été capable de détail
et sur un mur de mètres de platine gras
côté de l'autre ou même de de prendre
des cours de breakdance
j'ai toujours voulu créer des choses
parce que parce que je suis né à chennai
l'aquatinte je suis un bien 189
j'ai 27 ans aujourd'hui j'ai grandi dans
le 19ème et je me suis toujours sentie
fine actuelle parce que en tant que
créatif j'ai toujours voulu tout changer
tout bousculer j'ai créé ma première
marque de vêtements ma première boîte à
17 ans elle s'appelait des garçons
faucher justement parce que j'étais
fauché et j'ai créé un noeud désormais
mandat logo mondialement connu c'est un
petit peu marcher mais j'ai aussi connu
beaucoup d'échecs
je vais monter d'autres voix qui n'ont
pas bien marché et pas mal d'amis dans
la salle qui en sont témoins et j'ai
voulu analyser un petit peu les erreurs
pourquoi es tu
et du coup j'ai commencé à réfléchir a
observé le mot qui m'entouraient j'ai
sans doute voulu trop respecté les
règles de business d'entrepreneuriat
trop respecté un business plan des
règles marketing alors que ça ne me
correspondait pas vraiment j'ai arrêté
l'école en j'arrêtais lieu
j'ai arrêté mes études en 2011 en dix
ans pas parce que je ne savais pas quoi
faire ou comment faire mais justement
parce que je savais très précisément que
je voulais créer des choses j'ai voulu
régler mes comptes est que le présent
aimé prendre position sur le monde
actuel mai 2011 c'est pas seulement
l'arrêt de mes études c'est le monde
continue de tourner c'est le début du
printemps arabe
on a pu tout voir ces manifestations à
travers le monde et voir des peuples
accéder à la liberté et c'est vrai que
ces peuples là il avait tous un petit
peu ces manifestants les avait tous un
petit peu le même look le visage caché
la tête recouverte souvent il portait un
sweat à capuche un hoodie le hoodie
historiquement c'est un vêtement un
vêtement créé par les ouvriers de
chantier pour travailler confortablement
en hiver mais qui a été très vite repris
par la culture hip hop
je veux dire par là que grafite et
artistes ils pouvaient taguer des murs
les visages cachés et caché sa bombe
dans la robe dans sa page de peinture
c'est un petit peu pour ces raisons là
que que j'ai créé la marque défend de
paris avec deux associés en 2013 et le
succès a été un petit peu magique on
hier à succès fulgurant et du coup j'ai
envie de vous parler de ce succès de
manière comme un tour de magie en trois
étapes la première étape serait donc le
la promesse la seconde le tour et la
troisième le prestige donc la promesse
alors chaque année le time magazine et
villa la personnalité de l'année
généralement c'était un entrepreneur
apolitique
un scientifique qui avait fait une
découverte mais en 2000 - en 2011
c'est justement pas une personnalité
mais un personnage c'est le
protestataire
c'est un anonyme il faisait partie des
ces 99 % la tuerie des 99% c'est un
anonyme qui qui l'ont qui ont représenté
justement encore une fois avec ce visage
caché sa tête couverte et le regard
intrigant ça m'a un petit peu râpé cette
idée que j'ai parlé du sweat à capuche
et je me suis dit je me suis dit ouh
pourquoi né pas parler d'engagement est
confronté l'engagement est avec un
vêtement contemporain de ce vêtement là
serait donc le sweat à capuche ses
usages ses pratiques et c'est pour ça
que j'ai décidé de créer la marque be
fans paris et mais observez le monde qui
nous entoure ça ne suffit pas il faut un
triller des gens lancé un projet c'est
certes observer ce qui se passe autour
de nous mais c'est aussi répondre à des
questions ça qu'on passe à la deuxième
partie qui est le tour alors les
questions qu'on se posait sait comment
lancer une marque de vêtements avoir
aimé avoir un message protestataires à
la fois comment plaire aux jeunes
comment plaire aux leaders d'opinion
mais aussi comment mais aussi comment
gagner des parts de marché sur un marché
qui est hyper compliqué du streetwear
alors on a eu beaucoup de chance on a eu
un logo fort et on a travaillé le
marketing de la rumeur alors par chance
je parlais de la sérendipité ce concept
un peu ce concept de chercher quelque
chose et trouver quelque chose d'encore
encore plus heureux on a à l'époque un
habitant en colocation on était avec mes
deux associés arnaud et jérémy et et ont
gardé plein de films tous les soirs
qu'on a vu au cinéma club
hier soir on est tombé sur le film
johnny mad dog et de mathieu kassovitz
c'est un film qui traite des enfants
soldats et ce film nous avons envoyé
tellement bouleversée
on l'a regardé trois quatre soirs de
suite et on débattait son sujet on s'est
dit pourquoi ne pas créer quelque chose
pour financer l'association de mathieu
kassovitz alors soir on est mené avec
cette idée lançons une marque de bougies
une marque de bouger en forme de grenade
avec cette idée que la bougie en fondant
ferait disparaître larmes et
symboliserait désarmement j'ai mon
associé jérémy qu'il fonctionne un peu
comme un moteur souvent on est on parle
on débat on a des idées mais le
lendemain ne les réalise pas lui c'est
lever le lendemain matin la réaliser et
3 4 semaines plus tard on l'avait 2000
bougies chez nous et on n'avait vraiment
aucune stratégique alors on s'est dit
pourquoi ne pas organiser une soirée
lancement dans un bar invitez des amis
des amis d'amis et parfois ses amis
d'amis d'amis hamel des journalistes des
influenceurs nos combats ont organisé
cette soirée on l'avait prévu donné 200
bougies
alors pour distinguer le staff de des
invités on leur a fait le portait un tee
shirt un tee shirt avec le logo à la fin
de la soirée commence à faire les
comptes on voulait donner 200 bougies en
réalise par donné qu'une rappel et tout
le monde s'en foutait vraiment de ses
bougies
est ce qui les intéressait vraiment
c'était ce logo ce tee shirt on a eu des
questions ouais mais qu'est ce que c'est
exactement je comprends pas et là on a
peut-être une intelligence d'esprit de
se dire bah non arrêtons les jetons ses
2000 bougies et faisons une marque de
vêtements c'est pour ça que je parle de
sérendipité
mais la sérendipité elle est aussi
intervenue dans un autre truc c'est que
nos photos naveen identité visuelle très
noir et blanc c'est pas parce qu'on
l'avait choisie c'est justement on
n'était pas très bon photographe et
quand on est un flic noir et blanc les
photos rendez toujours mieux le
stratégique de notre point de vue je
voulais développer ça c'est le logo fort
alors c'est clair tout le goût il
intrigue on se pose des questions
différentes on a de la chance et carmaux
c'est un mot qui veut dire la même chose
dans toutes les langues
un peu comme mode justice donc ça permet
une mémorisation instantanée mais
ceux-ci ou un peu une pirouette
graphique la kalachnikov aller dans le
sens contraire de lecture et c'est chez
nous pas une kalachnikov pour attaquer
une kalachnikov défensive quand on veut
défendre quelque chose défendre des
causes c'est ce qui nous a permis un
petit peu de monter le buzz d'avoir du
buzz de susciter de l'intérêt et de
travailler les messages brouillés
on a toujours
c'est vrai que on a toujours eu mais
j'ai personnellement toujours hors
espagne et fascination pour les armes et
paradoxalement paradoxalement je savais
pas comment travailler et je me suis dit
utilisons larmes utilisant l'imagerie
armé pour défendre quelque chose une
fois que ces théories ont en tête sont
ces 10 mettant en place une stratégie
marketing et stratégie marketing online
et offline
c'est qu'on a commencé à offrir des
flames
je veux dire par là pour la commencer à
offrir des sweats à capuche à tout le
monde à des amis d'amis des amis d'amis
et un jour c'est vrai avec un peu de
chance on allie un ami qui s'appelle
brahim zaibat qu'il a offert à madonna
est là sachant entité tous que c'est
sûrement les nikon et un jours madonna a
porté un au sweat à capuche à new york
et à le buzz était lancée
on a eu la bbc qui nous a appelés que
vous a demandé mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça si je prends comprends pas elle a
un sweat à capuche avec rey défend de
paris et le pire dans cette histoire
c'est qu'à l'époque on n'était pas
encore une marque des vêtements sur
facebook on était en l'église
organisations religieuses ont posé des
questions ont soulevé des questions on
savait pertinemment qu'on allait
apporter des réponses on l'avait pensé
mais on voulait attirer les jeunes chez
attirer les jeunes et les jeunes ont
toujours cette culture là c'est ce culte
du secret du phénomène de groupe
l'effet de gang donc pour attirer les
jeunes on devait si on aurait aussi on
avait commencé à parler de d'humanitaire
tout de suite les jeunes ont tendance un
petit peu à fuir je parle de jeunes je
parle déjà un mois de 14 à 16 ans aux 14
à 18 ans et nous avec c'est avec ce
groupe facebook c'est cette page
facebook les jeunes sous les jets se
sont plu s commencé à poser des
questions et c'est là on arrive à la
troisième partie de ma représentation
qui est le prestige
on l'avait soulevé plein de questions
dit fin de paris contre qui contre quoi
comment les gens se posaient des
questions il y avait des débats sur
notre page facebook et nous on se devait
se révéler ce qu'on était vraiment le
but recherché je vous rappelle qu'on
avait voulu à la base créer une marque
de bougies et de reverser les fonds à
l'association johnny mad dog de mathieu
kassovitz donc le 26 juin
c'était la date c'était le jour de la
première delà du début de la fashion
week à paris
on décide de révéler par une vidéo qu'on
est certes une marque de vêtements
une marque de vêtements cool mais
surtout qu on reverse de l'argent de
l'argent à des associations humanitaires
et on intervient avec trois logos le
define coexistent qui permet de financer
notre association différente paris et le
différend human right et children wright
qui permet de financer l'association de
madonna à l'époque rires flight mais ce
qui a le plus important pour nous c'est
pas seulement
l'humanitaire c'est donner de l'argent à
des associations c'est plus c'était
plutôt cédé plutôt l'humanisme c'est que
tout le monde puisse s'approprier le
mode iphone et défendre sa cause la
cause qu'ils le souhaitent
aujourd'hui des dizaines de ce type là
il y en a partout dans le monde que nous
appartient pas il ya des différences r&b
jazz est distingué kosovo des dif en
algérie et pour le coup on n'a rien fait
pour ils ont les gens ne reprenne tout
simplement le logo apposent leur leur
cause sûrement parce qu'on n'a jamais
imposé storytelling et parce que notre
nos messages sont brouillées les gens
peuvent se l'approprier
paradoxalement c'est ce qui m'amène un
petit peu à la conclusion et j'ai envie
de dire
l'objectif le thème de cette soirée
c'était 7 milliards des défis et les
défis premier pour nous c'est coexistent
s'il vous plaît coexistent on est
peut-être pour les étudiants de l'est
des mini psy qui cherchent à
entreprendre c'est n'attendez pas
d'avoir une méta idées pour vous lancer
vous êtes nos histoires le prouve chaque
idée le greffon d'une autre idée on n'a
pas vraiment créé de choses on a fait
les choses sont justes ajoutées les unes
aux autres
l'adéquation au projet fait vraiment ce
que vous aimez suite si vous aimez la
musique fête de la musique si vous aimez
la fête de la et parfois si vous aimez
rien faire pendant un moment fait rien
et profiter de ce moment là et et
surtout voilà je vais conclure avec avec
une phrase d'un groupe de rap qui
s'appelle la mafia café et comme la
misère des biens dire prends des risques
et surtout de choc voilà merci